so you know life life is an anti
entropic phenomenon in a universe in
which the second law of thermodynamics
entropy is breaking everything down life
is a brief upwelling of structure
against chaos life moves towards greater
complexity and organization life
overcomes limits and as Bucky fuller
used to say life is anti-entropic life
needs energy and energy my friends as
you know is a hot-button topic these
days the dream is fusion the idea that
you could put energy to something and
actually get more energy out of it than
you put in and so far it has eluded us
but it has captured our imagination and
so now in the South of France in the
Alpine forests a machine called an
international thermonuclear experimental
reactor is literally the sparking and
the controlling of a self-sustaining
synthetic star this machine promises to
fulfill the dream of fusion it'll
literally be on earth a synthetic
self-sustaining star mankind the species
that overcomes and transcends limits
Humanity is ushering in its trans
humanity by potentially solving the
problem of energy a self-sustaining
synthetic star the dream to get more
energy out of it than you put in so
whether it ends up working we shall find
out just the idea of think of something
more magnificent
maybe a little heretical as well but
magnificent I just I'm gonna create a
star I'm gonna create a star alright
guys so be sure to check out our sister
network seeker where we explore travel
adventure culture and amazing stories
from around the globe as human beings
exploring is in our nature we want to
learn and discover until we are able to
better comprehend not only the world but
ourselves what is without becomes within